foreign
what's up Lucy
hey Dr John how are you partying what
are you up to
I am sitting in my office wondering if
you can help me with something I'm not
partying and hey we can help each other
let's do this all right so what's up
sounds good so I have the awesome
privilege of running a Crisis Pregnancy
Center
um in a rural town oh good for you hey
can we just can I celebrate you thank
you yeah thank you it takes a lot of us
but you don't make enough money for what
you're doing you it says Crisis
Pregnancy on your business card but you
do way way more than that
and you do that way way for more people
than just those
scared terrified soon-to-be moms who
show up in at your front door thank you
thank you thank you thank you it's an
awesome privilege you're such a gift man
you're on the express I just I'm
grateful for you thank you all right so
how can I help thank you
okay so uh obviously uh in your case as
well over over the time that we have
with individuals we're not going to be
able to make a difference in each of
their lives because they each have a
choice but I do want to focus on making
a choice for some that are looking at
depending on the government
for a lifetime of assistance instead of
just for a season again very rural area
a lot of Section 8 housing like the
majority of the town is Section 8
housing government assistance free
school lunches and it's generationally
just accepted that that's how they have
to live
and we have Financial classes in place
beyond just our parenting and pregnancy
classes that we want to incorporate some
sort of different tactic or some sort of
additional tactic that I could speak
into their lives that hey you are worth
so much more than just living
this one check from the government every
month and Beyond you are worth going to
school if that is something that you
want to uh
seek out how can I get them to listen to
me when generationally it's been
accepted it's even encouraged Dr John in
our area to have children to continue to
continue this cycle and again I'm not
going to reach everybody and that's okay
but for the one that will listen what's
a tactic that I can incorporate that I
may not be thinking of now
um man that's such a great great
question
um and you know this I'm so I'm saying
this for the audience you're talking
about asking somebody
who's watched their grandparents and
their parents and their friends
grandparents and their friends parents
jump in a stream that's just going to
carry them on and what we're asking them
to do what you're asking them to do is I
want you to walk into the ocean and swim
against that tide and I want you to swim
all the way out because you have no idea
what's out there farther than you can
see
absolutely so what we're asking them to
do is something virtually impossible and
here's why they have no picture of what
this looks like it's it's all unicorns
and rainbows and cotton candy because
they've never seen it they've never
experienced they don't know what it is
so it's like it's like
I just think about like uh listen like
when I was a high school teacher and
you'd listen to kids talking about like
making out with with you know somebody
who had never made out them trying to
explain it to each other wasn't was
always hilarious
because it's like you are in you have no
idea right and so
um and probably of all the the analogies
I could have given you that was the
worst I like I just High School boys
talking about making out but here's
here's the thing
they have to have a new picture of what
this looks like and this new picture is
going to be at odds with everything they
know and so
I'm thinking of a couple of things I've
used over the years almost always it is
involving people who have left
made the changes in inviting them and
sometimes paying them to come back
because somebody who's left and has gone
on to Community College and then gone to
get a four-year degree at a local school
or whatever the thing is there they they
went and got their welding certificate
and they're making some money
they walk back in the door and everybody
goes oh that person looks just like me
that person's me you Lucy you're not
you're the boss you're Miss right you're
you're the you're the man you're the the
in parentheses whoa you're the you're
the man right
but she looks just like us or he looks
just like us
um
this is years ago that I read this
literature so it may have shifted but it
used to be that somebody walks into a
room that's full of people and they scan
that room
for right to left or left to right and
they give that room seven seconds to for
their body to decide I belong here or I
do not belong here
somebody stands up in front of them and
says I'm one of you you get seven
seconds and and again that's not that's
not precise but somebody who's been
there and comes back is crucial somebody
who's had success at a local school or
is in school now that comes back and
says let me tell you about how different
your life can be
somebody who crawled their way out there
you go and most people who crawled their
way out had a coach or somebody that
carried them a little bit of the way or
that one English teacher or that one
geometry teacher whoever who said hey
hold on uh my mom is a perfect example
of it
um just didn't have any pictures of
educated women in her family lineage and
then one teacher at one Community
College Class said
hey I don't know if you know this but
you're the smartest kid in this class
she's like I'm not a kid I'm 43 years
old and she says I know and I don't want
you to stop and uh you've probably heard
you've probably heard me talk about my
mom here but zero schooling until 42
none and graduated with her PhD at 57
and she's in her 70s and she's going to
do her last summer at Oxford this summer
like she's just a complete back uh
second half of her life but because a
couple of professors said holy smokes
you got something really special right
and they just she said I can be one of
you guys I can be one of y'all right and
so that's that's number one
um the second one is
often I find people
um so I I have a thing whenever I go do
public I go do speeches I go do talks I
always have really
um misleading titles of my talks and
here's why people look at that title
they prejudge it they call it they
already think they know how this thing
ends and they check out before you even
start
so I want you to look at the names of
your classes if you have a parenting
class A how to be married class and then
a money class
it's very easy to look at that and go I
don't need that I got that the like my
check just comes
if you had a life 101 course or a how to
be happy course or how to have less
um abuse in your life course
and in these like and I'm trying to
think of just titles that might appeal
to folks in
um that you are working with
um folks who have been on the other side
of opiate recovery and they're and they
can come back and say hey here's what
this looks like on the other side of
this right because I know you deal with
that too I'm certain so right being able
to say um here's a class that you might
be interested in in that class we're
going to weave the financial principles
into that class
um I like that this is an aside I'm
going to send you five Financial Peace
University courses that you can give
away okay thank you for a year and so if
somebody comes in and you it's all the
videos they can log in check out all the
videos you could probably even show the
videos in a class I don't know how all
that works you can talk to Jenna um and
figure out how that works but
um yeah we've already got one client in
there and she's loving it with her
husband so okay all right great
um the one cool thing is is most people
think Financial Peace is just about
getting out of debt that's a part of it
but it's the the the master Mastery of
that course is empowerment you can do
anything
right and there's something about here's
a tiny direct path it's very simple and
it's very straightforward so even when
you get into the dark and you're in the
middle of the ocean and you've been
swimming and you can't see Shore and you
can't see where you're headed
you know that okay I just gotta keep
going I just gotta keep going I just
gotta keep going
so those are a couple of my ideas there
um
what's something you've tried that
doesn't work at all
we encourage
um continuing education a lot of our
clients come without even a high school
diploma so if they if they promise to go
to their help classes to study for the
GED test we pay for that test so that is
one thing that we would love to see more
clients take advantage of just doesn't
happen I don't know if that's a
strategic thing where we have to find
some babysitters or we have to just
speak more encouragement into there that
it can do it because like you said not
every teacher is going to encourage them
right and do that what I noticed is just
taking something simple uh like Maslow's
hierarchy
a lot of the programs like Hey we're
gonna help you handle your money we're
gonna help you get a job we're going to
help you
um go to school
and on Maslow's hierarchy it you can't
do those higher order things
if I'm afraid of getting my head bashed
in at night or if my Granddad comes home
and lives with us and he's messed out
all the time or if Mom has taken my
check in forging my social security
number and taken our my baby's formula
money too right so it it's I tended to
use the masos hierarchy to say how many
of these needs can I solve on my own and
how many of these can I make sure that
there are a referral direct referrals
and not just well here's the list of
psychiatrists in the area but where are
some direct I'd go meet with people but
where are some direct referrals and
resources there on that Maslow's
hierarchy that would allow people to
then come in and go okay
my kids are safe I'm safe I got a warm
place to live I got a full belly
now I'm ready to learn I'm ready to
change my life and that's hard for folks
who are living a section I mean just two
are just grinding it and grinding it and
grinding it
um
I think it's gonna be a fun Retreat for
you and your staff to just reimagine the
whole thing and say how do we provide
pictures
so that the folks who walk in our doors
can say okay I'm here
oh but I see her
could be there
I see him I could be over there I could
be there
where is a men's group for a group of
guys to get together in your community
just to say I'm not okay how are you
guys or a group of new moms or a group
of where can people get together and see
each other
and then you get a new picture and you
get a new picture then I can suddenly I
suddenly have a path forward when that
one kid in your neighborhood makes it
out
everybody goes okay I can do that if he
can do that I can do that
and I may not make it all the way to
where he made it but I can at least I
can at least uh I can at least go for it
thank you so so so much for your work
Lucy hope that helps um you're
infinitely more wise in this stuff than
I am because you're living it every day
but I hope those couple of those
suggestions weren't too lame and I hope
they help a little bit